.
♪ ♪
>> FEARS OF A RED WAVE RAMPING
UP FOR DEMOCRATS, THE PARTY IN A
TIZZY OVER TERRIBLE MESSAGING.
NOW, THEY'VE GOT ANOTHER MAJOR
PROBLEM.
DEMOCRATS ARE WORRIED THAT
KAMALA HARRIS' POOR POLLING
COULD COST THEM IN THE MIDTERMS.
REPORTEDLY HELD A CRISIS DINNER.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY ARE BLAMING HARRIS' LOW
APPROVAL RATINGS ON SEXISM IN
THE MEDIA.
"CRISIS DINNER!"
>> Greg: THAT WAS THE NAME OF
MY BAND AND THE '90s, IT WAS A
NU END.
IT DIDN'T WORK OUT.
WHY IS IT CALLED A CRISIS
DINNER?
SHE WAS COOKING IT.
[LAUGHTER]
IF IT'S URGENT, YOU DON'T HAVE A
CRISIS DINNER.
NO ONE IS GOING TO TELL YOU THAT
YOU SUCK TO YOUR FACE.
THEY WILL GO "IT'S NOT YOU, IT'S
NOT YOU," WHICH IS WHY SHE'S
MADE IT THIS FAR.
IT'S NOT HER FAULT.
BLAMING HER IS A STRATEGY, OR
FOR BIDEN'S WHITE HOUSE AND THE
DEMOCRATS WIRELESS -- SO YOU
DON'T FOCUS ON THE HORRIBLE
MESSAGING.
THE RED WAVE IS LINKED TO THE
CRIME WAVE AND AUTHORITARIAN
WAVE.
THOSE ARE THE TWO AWAY LIVES
THAT MATTER.
SHE'S NOT VERY GOOD.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
YOU START FOCUSING ON HER, YOU
ARE LETTING ALL THESE OTHER
IDIOTS OFF THE HOOK.
I WILL STOP THERE.
>> Dagen: I WAS TALKING BUT
THE REAL PROVINCE, JESSE,
SATAN'S TRINITY.
HIGH COST, INFLATION, COVID.
KAMALA HARRIS HAS NOTHING TO DO
WITH THAT.
THAT IS BIDEN ALONE AND HIS
CRONIES.
>> Jesse: SMARTEST THING BIDEN
DID WAS MAKE KAMALA THOSE ARE OF
THE BOARD ROOM, AND NOW WE ARE
TALKING ABOUT KAMALA INSTEAD OF
JOE.
THAT WAS THE STRATEGY.
SHE'S A WOUNDED ANIMAL BECAUSE
THE BORDER IS IN CRISIS.
ALL OF THE TOP WOMEN IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY WENT OVER TO
THIS ;-) SOIREE IN GEORGETOWN
AND LEAKED
IT.
THEY LINKED THAT THIS WAS A
CRISIS.
THEY CHARACTERIZED THEMSELVES AS
THIS BIG GROUP OF POWERFUL
OPERATIVES THAT ARE GOING TO
SAVE KAMALA HARRIS FROM THE
SEXIST MEDIA.
IT'S ALSO A WARNING SHOT TO THE
MEDIA, YOU KNOW HOW SHE SOLVES
THE PROBLEM CUSTOMER DO A
GOOD JOB ON THE BORDER.
>> Dagen: WITH A LET
KAMALA HARRIS GO TO THE BORDER?
SHE WAS NEARBY.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Richard: A COUPLE OF THINGS
HERE.
BOONE, I'VE I'VE WORKED A CRISIS
BEFORE.
YOU HAVE DAILY MEETINGS.
[LAUGHTER]
NUMBER TWO, I LOOK AT THE
ATTENDEE LIST.
I KNOW MOST OF THOSE PEOPLE.
SOME ARE FORMER COLLEAGUES IN
RESULT.
WE WERE SERVING SANDWICHES.
[LAUGHTER]
ONE OF THE TOPICS OF
CONVERSATION, THE CONVERSATION
IS HOW THEY CAN SUPPORT THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
ALMOST 1 MILLION JOBS ADDED, THE
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WE HAVE
SEEN SINCE THE BEGINNING OF THE
PANDEMIC.
AMERICA'S COMING BACK.
>> Greg: GET RID OF THE
LANDLORD'S PROBLEM >> Richard:
I THINK BEYOND THAT, THE WEEKEND
WILL ALSO SEE BOATING ACTIVITY
IN THE SENATE.
THIS IS ALMOST AFTER FIVE YEARS
ON INFRASTRUCTURE.
WE NEED NEW AIRPORTS AND ROADS.
MORE PROGRESS THE PRESENT CAME
TO WASHINGTON, HIM AND
KAMALA HARRIS CAME TO
WASHINGTON.
THEY SAID THEY WOULD TRY TO
BRING DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
TOGETHER.
THEY WILL GET IT DONE THIS
WEEKEND.
>> Greg: WELL DONE, RICHARD!
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dagen: KEEP TALKING ABOUT
THE ECONOMY BEING ON FIRE.
THEN THE MORATORIUM.
>> Richard: $1 BILLION IS
NOTHING TO SNEEZE AT.
>> Shannon: STUDENT LOANS AS
WELL.
>> Dagen: ANOTHER
$5.5 TRILLION THEY WANT TO
SPEND.
QUICKLY COMING TO JESSE'S POINT,
YOU'VE HEARD THE MESSAGING ON
"THE VIEW COMICAL SCHOOLS WHAT'S
WHERE JOEY BEHAR SAID "LET'S SEE
WHY THEY ARE GOING AFTER
KAMALA HARRIS, SHE IS A WOMAN
AND BLACK, I ALMOST FORGOT."
THAT'S A WARNING TO ANY
DEMOCRATS WHO THREATEN HER OR
TRY TO CHALLENGE HER.
>> Shannon: I TALKED ABOUT
THIS MEMO LAST WEEK.
WE LITERALLY GOT THIS MEMO FROM
A NUMBER OF WOMEN'S GROUPS
BEFORE THE ELECTION THAT SAID
"IF YOU GO AFTER HER, IT WILL BE
CONSIDERED SEXISM AND RACISM."
IT WAS A LITERAL MEMO.
THIS IS SO BIZARRE.
THEY ARE TELLING US IN ADVANCE
THAT IF YOU CRITICIZE HER, THIS
IS WHAT IT'S GOING TO BE
ATTRIBUTE IT TO.
WE KNOW THAT THE OFF YEAR
MIDTERM ELECTIONS FOR THE PARTY
IN POWER IN THE WHITE HOUSE IS
USUALLY NOT GOOD.
THEY ARE LOOKING AT A TOUGH YEAR
NEXT YEAR.
NPR SAID "THIS IS WHAT
REPUBLICANS WILL BE FOCUSING ON,
THE ECONOMY AND CRIME.
THEY WILL HAVE PLENTY TO TALK
ABOUT."
>> Greg: YOU LISTEN TO NPR?
>> Shannon: I WAS READING AN
ARTICLE.
[LAUGHTER]
THERE ARE ALSO OTHERS OUT THERE
CAUSING TROUBLE FOR THEM, THE
POSSIBLE RED WAVE, LIKE
CONGRESSWOMAN CORI BUSH.
THAT'S A HEADACHE FOR DEMOCRATS
TO SAY "WE DON'T NEED TO DEFUND
THE POLICE."
SHE SAID "YES, I MEAN DEFUNDED
THE POLICE CURED" THEY'VE GOT